abone ol
[Müzik]
bu
hepiniz hoşgeldiniz
bu salondaki bir çoğumuzu telefonda
hemen hemen her gün duyduğu bir soru var
size daha iyi hitap edebilmem için
İsminizi öğrenebilir miyim
Ama bu sonra beni çok rahatsız ederdi
her yanıt verme teşebbüsünde kendimi bir
bak dönüşünü tam orta yerinde bulur
derdim kendi kendime yanlış
anlaşılacağını bile bile izah mı etsem
yoksa bıraksam insanlar bana ezberlerin
den bir seslense ismim ayşıl
bu Ayşe'nin Ayşe'nin Ayşen ayçın değil
Lüleburgaz annesiyle bitiyor Halbuki ben
çoğu zaman hiç de güle Burgaz kadar uzun
ve karmaşık bir kelime gibi
hissetmiyorum Ben basit olmak istiyorum
birkaç yakın arkadaşımın lisedeyken Sen
tam bir Barbie giydin dediği o yerde o
Barbie olarak kendi içimde günde üç öğün
yer sofraları kuruyordum ben
E tamam o ki bazen hiç de göründüğümüz
gibi ki hissetmiyoruz e göründüğün gibi
hissetme asken dünyaya kendini
olabilecek en sade yerden haykırmanın ne
kadar zor olabileceğini heralde hepiniz
tahmin edebiliyorsunuz dur Üstüne üstlük
Üstüne üstlük Benim ismim de Aşina
olunan un birisinde gerisinde kalıyor
yani kısacası ilk etapta bir miktar
tanımsız İşte bu tanımsız lığın Bir nevi
Don kişot'um Ben bilinmeyenle daha önce
duyulmayan benim mücadelem
bir
yandan biliyor musunuz yine bu ismim
sayesinde her gün yeniden inşa ediyorum
kendimi Ben her gün insanlara nasıl
anılmak istediğimi nasıl çağırmak
istediğimi ve ben olmayı anlatıyorum bu
anlatma ve anlama beni çok diri tutuyor
çünkü ben her anlattığımda Aslında
Karşımdaki insanı da anlamak için
Aramızda bir alan açmış oluyorum bu alan
beni merakımdan dürtüyor ve tahmin
edebileceğiniz gibi bu merak sayesinde
de çokça soru sorabiliyor um Benim
kendime her gün sorular soruyorum Adın
ne senin diyorum
ve bu adanın manası nasıl bir yaşam
kurdum kendini bu ismi sana koyanlar
acaba senin için nasıl bir hayat
dilediler
var ya sen o hayatım neresindesin
başka bir isimle yaşıyor olsaydın Acaba
nasıl biri olurdum ne istiyorsun bu
hayattan Benim sorularım bu şekilde
belirginleşti kçe yanıtları daha da bir
iştahla arar olduk Çünkü ben fark ettim
ki her soru sorduğumda kendime bir adım
yanaşırken her cevap arayışında ise
başkalarına doğru adım lıyoruz
bu ve bunu fark ettim bu farkındalık
Üniversitesi elinde iyice arttı tahmin
edebileceğiniz gibi ve Neticede bir
baktım ki Belki bu Açıklar biraz 3 bölüm
değiştirdikten sonra psikolog olabildim
ve sorularımı bulamadım kadarıyla devam
ettiğimde de bütün yollarım akademiye
çıktı akademiye baş
koydum Dolayısıyla soru sormaktan
bahsederken bu soru sorma ediniz son
derece çocuksu dur değil mi çocuk
etrafını Bu alemi kendisini tanımladık
ça güvende hisseder bunun için soru
sorar sustukça ise içte ve dışta
yabancılaşır korkar kaygılanır
bu
en kötüsü topyekûn Belki de hissetmez
olur nasıl ulaşır ufak kalbi şimdi bu
çocuk ilkokul sıralarının en önünde
oturuyor hatta derste de gayet ilgili
gözüküyor olabilir Bir İşte en yakından
takip edilmesi gerekilen çocukta bu
çocuktur Neden mi Çünkü içi atmak Efendi
olmak Suskun olmak aslında hiç de
çocuksu değildir
Aferin sana Uslu çocuk hep böyle ol
tamam mı dediğimizde Uslu çocuk kim
bu çocuk Sizsiniz [ __ ] çocuk sizin
anneniz babanız abiniz ablanız
kardeşiniz sevdiğiniz
Ama bu Uslu çocuk
ebeveynlerini büyüklerini Her koşulda
memnun etmeye çalışacağım onların
sözünden çıkmayan itaatkar bir çocuk bu
Uslu çocuk kendi keşif merak ve özgürlük
duygusuna karşılık
büyüklerinin şartlı onayını şartı
sevgisinin cebine koyan çocuk bu çocuk
sorularını merakını bir gün çok ihtiyacı
olduğunda dahi hatırlayacağı kadar
derinlere gömen bir çocuk
Sen hangi sorularımız sorularımız her
gün ne uğruna yaşadığımızın aynasıdır
Bir de bir hesap defterimiz dir yani
Sahi merak ediyorum Acaba Sizler her gün
kendinizi hangi soruları soruyorsunuz Şu
an ne hissediyorum diye mi soruyorsunuz
Neden ben diye mi ya da belki de çoktan
vazgeçtiniz artık soru sormuyorsun zaman
hep aynı cümleleri kuruyorsunuz bu
insanların hiç güven olmuyor gibi Tüm bu
sorular size mi ait yoksa
bir yakınınızın Ya bir türlü sormaya
cesaret edemediği ya da
o cevabını aramak için o yolculuğa
çıkamadığı yola Şimdi siz mi baş
koydunuz O soru senin Bu soru benim o
yük senin bu yük de benim diye
ayrıştırma bilmenin en büyüğü
yollarından biri aile terapisi
kuramcıların dan ölü bulanın işaret
ettiği gibi soyağacı çalışması yapmak
Evet bu da tek dikkat etmemiz gereken
şeylerden bir tanesi bu soyağacı
çalışmasında ciddi mizde en az üç kuşak
kadar önce gide Bilmemiz gerekiyor ve
tabi tahmin edebileceğiniz gibi yeni
sorular soruyor olacağız bu büyüklerimiz
atalarımız evlendiyse kimin evrende
nasıl bir hikaye evlendi çocukları Oldu
mu Okey istenilen çocuklar miydi kaza
kurşunu muydu bu insanlar nasıl Anılır
nasıl bilinirler Didi kronik
hastalıkları var mıydı neden öldüler
aynı şekilde hücresel biyolojinin de
Yani tıbbında bu tekrarlayan acılarımıza
bakmamız için önerdiği yani yerlerden
birisidir sonra çalışması öyleki Bununla
ilgili atasözlerimiz dahi var bizim Baba
koruk yer oğlunun dişi kamaşır
Baba eder Oğuz öder Hadi isterseniz
şimdi bu baba oğul ilişkisindeki olur
Şöyle bir kenara koyalım ve onunla
ilgili kısaca bir hikaye vurgulayalım
ve bu erkek evlat babasını çok genç
yaşta kaybetmiş olsun ona uzun uzun İzah
edilen o kocaman baba imgesini kendi
hayatında yaşatmak için Herkese yemin
etmiş olsun attığı her adıma dahil
babasının gölgesi düşsün kelimelerini
babasının kimlerle değiş tokuş etmiştir
olsun Bu çocuk efendi olmaktan ötürü bir
türlü babasının kaybının O Vahşi
kıyısına temas edememiş yasını
dokunmadıkça da tüm duygularından tüm
arzularından
bu perabet etmiş olsun
abone ol
Evet şimdi anlattığım bu çocuk büyüyünce
birçoğumuzun ketum
diyeceğim sever ama belli etmez
diyeceğim tatil nedir bilmez hep çalıştı
diyeceği o adamın küçüklüğünü çocuk
duydu bu insan içten içe hiç anlamadı bu
yaşama
bu ayet olamadı buralara Köksal alamadı
hep en iyi bildiğini tutuldu ya bir aile
kurmaya ya Aileyi korumaya ya da
kendisine işine arabaya ancak kendi
yaşam öyküsünün esas oğlanı türlü
kendisi olamadı
mi
Evet şimdi bu yetişkin insanın
özelliklerini şöyle birazcık aklımızda
tutarak onun başına gelebilecek en Zorlu
hastalıklardan birini tahmin edelim
Azrail Ne dersiniz
ki bu adam kendi merakını babasıyla
beraber diri diri toprağa dönmüş görmüş
bir insan bu adam
bir türlü anlamlandıramadığım hayatını
sıradan aktivitelerle normalleştirmeye
çalışmış biri Ve şimdi bir türlü
yeterince efkarl Anam adı bir türlü
yeterince öfkelenme mediği yasasıyla
dile gelmeyen hayalleriyle birlikte
Yavaş yavaş unutsa kim olduğunu çok mu
şaşırırız Yok canım abartma Diğerlerini
de olabilir Neticede az rhymer olmanın
öncelikli olarak kadın olmakta
obezite geçmişiyle otoimmün
hastalıklarla
bu diyabet ile ilişkisi var
diyebilirsiniz Bunların hepsi doğru da
ancak farkında mısın Saydım bu üç
hastalığında en belirgin ortak noktası
bir türlü aydınlığa kavuşturma mış olan
erken çocukluk travmaları
bu öteki yandan otuzlu yaşlarının
sonunda dahi insanlara alzaymır
olabiliyorlar artık hayatlarının
baharında Dolayısıyla
en ileri yaş artık bir risk faktörü
değil ancak gelişmemiş ülkelerde yaşıyor
olmak Can hocamızın da söylediği gibi
gerçek bir risk faktörü
Bu elbette gelişmemiş ülke derken
sağlıklı daha kısıtlı erişim den tutunda
çevre kirliliğinden bahsediyoruz Bunlar
doğru ancak benim gelişmemiş ülkeyi ele
aldığım yer yeterince gelişmemiş olan
duygusal sözcükte harcı Bununla ilgili
Müsadenizle iki kısa öykü olacak gerçek
bir tanesi Amerika'da geçecek diğeri
Türkiye'de geçecek
yüksek lisansımı yapıyorum amerikadayım
Ve bir yıl boyunca da Akademik olarak
zorluk yaşayan göçmen göçmen çocukların
yollandı bir orta okulda görevliyim
Burada bir sürü çocuğun gelişimini takip
edeceğim onlarla bireysel seanslar
yapacağım buraya kadar herşey çok güzel
İnanır mısınız bu çocuklarım hala
unutamam ben ile başlayan cümlelerine
kendileri için kullandıkları o zengin
sıfatları olaylara geleceklerine yönelik
duydukları o müthiş meraklı Bu
çocukların anne-babaları onlardan hiç
dinlemedim ben
Abi bu eve ebeveynleri yalnızca Veli
toplantılarına gele bildiklerinde
tanıdım Neden mi Çünkü bu çocukların
kendileri hakkında konuşma hürriyetleri
vardır kendi kelimeleri kendilerine ait
sesleri vardı Dolayısıyla ne ana
babalarının yükleriyle yaşamak zorunda
vardı ve arkadaşlarıyla ilgili dedikodu
yapmak zorunda vardır
bir diğer hikaye Türkiye'de geçiyor
olacak oldukça trajikomik sene
2002/2 annemin babasının çok şiddetli
şekilde Burnu kanıyor tüm aile çok
endişeleniyor ayda hemen hastaneye
tetkikler yapılıyor kardiyolojiden çok
güzel feedbackler geliyor geri
bildirimler gayet iyi babanı zaman
yollarını bir tıkanıklık yok Şahane
geriye çekilen emarın nörolog tarafından
bize yorumlanması kalıyor Anneannem o
sıralar kanser teşhisi ile
büyük bir mücadele veriyor Dolayısıyla
görüşme kim giriyor annem Şu an ne kadar
olan kapısından çıkmak üzere kendi olan
adımlarını sıklaştığını fark ediyor ve
tam o kapının ağzında o daracık alanda
şu sihirli sözcükleri duyuyor babanızı
sağlığıyla ilgili endişelenecek hiçbir
şey yok Yalnızca beyninde küçülme oraya
günler
ama bilmiyor ki hanımefendi ne olur
biraz oturun şimdi size zor bir
şeylerden bahsedeceğim
babanızda az rhymer var bu çok uzun bir
yol olacak sebeplerini size anlatamam
akla birlikte tam olarak bu sürücü
kolaylaştırabiliriz bazı bilgilerimiz
var hem bakım veren olarak hem de
hastanız için sizi söyleyeceğim birkaç
çift lafım var ne olur oturun
diyemiyorum demiyor susuyor saklanır
şu aradan bir yıl geçiyor Anneannem
ölüyor ve demo bilinmeyen alzaymır
hastalığı bir basamakları ikişer üçer
kızı tırmanmaya devam ediyor ilk
önceleri hiç birimiz idrak edemiyoruz
artan asabiyeti ne artan paran oyalarını
Çünkü o ketul olusuyor açıklamıyor
sormuyor merak etmiyor ve İnanır mısınız
ev hızlıca bir mezarlığa dönüyor
anneannemin cenazesi Salamın tam
ortasında bir daha oradan asla kalkmıyor
anneannemin ölümü dedemin önceden
tutamadığı yasların kabuklarını teker
teker Söküyor onun cenazesini yanına Bu
sefer dedemin çoktan ölmüş olan
annesinin cenazesi onun yanına babasının
cenazesi ve son olarak ise ona İsmini
vermiş olan Gencecik yaşta ölen abi
Cinan cenaze ekleniyor bitmedi
geçmişinden gelen o kocaman iflası da
ekleniyor tabloya ve son olarak ise iki
tane pırlanta gibi kız evladının Bu
hastalığı çok zor yollarla öğrenmek
zorunda kalmasından mütevellit kenarda
çürümüş olan hayallerinin cenazesi de bu
oraya o evde nefes alınmıyor
Bu dünyada her üç saniyede biri Ben de
maskesi geliyor konuluyor bu
teşhislerini üçte ikisi alzaymıra ait
var yani Yani Tüm bu insanlar bir günde
azalmış olmayacak Ya bir günde kim
olduklarını unutmayacaklar peyderpey
unutacaklar
Belki de tam da bu yüzden aslında en
başından biri unutmak için yaşıyorlar
beyinlerinde biriken o Beta amiloid
plaklar sustukların iç attıklarının
yarış getirdiklerinin tortuları
Ama bu İnsanlar hayatlarında ilk kez
çocuk oluyorlar işine gelince anlıyor
işine gelince anlamıyor yapmıyorlar
Onlar ilk kez çocuk oluyorlar Bir
yetişkin gövdesinde bir çocuğun
becerileriyle kavurucu bir ana baba
Özlemiyle yaşıyorlar ve İnanır mısınız
yine unutmak için yaşıyorlar ve hala
kendilerine ait değiller
ve
dolayısıyla şu ağzı heimer
hastalığı da bir nevi Benim ismim gibi
baştan sona teşhisinden tedavi süreci ne
kadar karmaşık ve tanımsız
ancak ben kendi mantı kendi adıma düşen
paydan adım aracılığıyla olsa bile her
gün izah edeceğim anlaşılma Sam bile kim
olduğumu ne yapmak istediğimi nasıl
anılmak istediğini ben hep anlatacağım
hep merakta kalacağım bir Sizlerde
isterseniz ama hiç duymayan insanlar
olun isterseniz bunun bilim kısmında
olan ya da hastanın kendisi olun Sizler
Lütfen soru sorun merakta ve araştırmada
kalın
ve büyüklerinizi atalarınızı bulun
farkedin köklerinizi yüklerinizi
ayrıştır ın
hep soru sorun Ha
bu arada
da olur da şimdiden merak edenler olursa
evet ismim aşıldı mânâsına Gelecek
olursak da Ay gibi ışıldayan insan demek
bir şey Çok teşekkürler Ha